gelée
Oh oh oh
[musique]
vaudou
Mugla
moi
Oh oh oh
[musique]
Murray
moi
Ufufu
Après tout, il existe des coronavirus provenant de divers parcs d'attractions et sociétés événementielles, donc cet été
Tout comme l'annulation
J'ai reçu de plus en plus d'appels et j'ai été choqué de constater qu'il y en avait plus que ce à quoi je m'attendais.
que
Peut-être que c'est juste de dire que je vais le supporter jusqu'à ce que le roulement printanier s'apaise
peut être
Je pense qu'il existe différentes opinions concernant les objections, mais nous ferons tout ce que nous pouvons
Une maison hantée même si elle prend une forme différente
Je veux continuer Je veux rendre heureux les gens que j'aime Je veux qu'ils aient peur
Je veux faire de mon mieux parce que j'ai le fort sentiment que
[musique]
moi
Avec le client dans la voiture
Si vous créez un système où des fantômes vous menacent parce que vous ne touchez pas la tête en bas, c'est ça.
Rendre les clients heureux en toute sérénité même dans les situations difficiles
Tout a commencé quand je pensais pouvoir créer une maison hantée.
Non
Si je suis surpris, je peux m'enfuir, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais ce trajet s'appelle une maison hantée, donc je suis tout le temps coincé dans la voiture, alors je m'enfuis
Il y a un moment où la peur de ne pas y parvenir est plus forte que la maison hantée de cet été.
Je n'entends pas le son de l'application s'il s'agit d'une voiture Kane, alors voici
Même si vous parlez si fort, cela ne sera pas transmis à l'intérieur, donc le son de la voix
J'ai déjà incorporé la voix d'un fantôme ou la voix d'un acteur dans le son qui jouait dans la voiture.
Le fait que nous agissions ensemble est très difficile cette fois-ci au garage automobile Ingenuity.
C'est un endroit appelé magasin qui se trouve de l'autre côté de la vitrine.
La distance avec le client n'est pas étroite et la distance sociale est correctement protégée
La distance entre vous et le client devient alors très étroite.
Il y a beaucoup de choses qui rendent intéressant de voir de près les réactions étonnantes.
dis la même chose
[musique]
Oh
Hummm
Ufufu
Oh oh oh
[musique]
Ouais